à 25 km au nord de Bruxelles
le 16 septembre dernier
Linda Doms une éducatrice pour enfants
handicapée ne se présente pas à son
travail
le lendemain son corps dénudé et
découvert gisant dans sa chambre
les premières constatations
révèlent qu'elle a subi de nombreux
coups notamment à la tête avec un bâton
c'est l'incompréhension pour Auguste
lobbyge son voisin qui parle d'une femme
discrète et sans histoire
c'est la maison du crime
elle était trop sociable trop bonne trop
gentille elle est de tout le monde
elle en faisait trop pour tout le monde
elle était passionnée par son travail
avec les enfants handicapés
la victime s'appelait Linda dooms elle
avait 53 ans
[Musique]
elle a été massacrée à coups de bâton
deux jours plus tôt
[Musique]
rapidement les policiers sont sur la
piste d'un ex petit ami de la victime un
amour de jeunesse un certain Renaud
hardi comme l'explique Gilles Blondo le
substitut du procureur de la République
il y avait en fait une rumeur que quand
elle avait une connaissance qui n'avait
pas vraiment une bonne réputation
et c'est sur ce plan là que que qu'on a
commencé l'enquête
les policiers ont fait une perquisition
chez cet homme un homme de 53 ans qui
est domicilié à Malines et c'est pendant
la perquisition fait qu'on a trouvé des
images vidéos
chez Renault Hardy une vidéo est
retrouvée dans la carte mémoire d'une
GoPro un appareil vidéo miniature comme
celui-ci
[Musique]
lorsque les enquêteurs visionnent cette
vidéo ils découvrent une scène atroce
une femme se faisant battre à mort il
réalise en fait qu'il s'agit de la
victime Linda dooms
son ancien petit ami a filmé chaque
instant de son agonie
face à cet élément matériel indéniable
en garde à vue Renaud hardi aurait avoué
le meurtre de son ex-compagne
il est mis en examen pour assassinat
puis incarcéré le 22 septembre dernier
l'affaire semble boucler mais le
comportement pervers de Renault Hardy
incite la justice à se demander s'il
n'aurait pas commis d'autres crimes
mais peut-être aussi Maria velcherts 82
ans et Anne Bourgoin 38 ans
sans compter une longue liste de
tentatives de meurtre
l'actrice belge vers les Eckermann et
d'autres femmes ont été également
violemment agressés toutes habité dans
cette région près de Malines
toutes auraient croisé la route de cet
homme aux mœurs étranges Renault Hardy
surnommé Renaud le fou
désigné aujourd'hui par certains comme
impossible tueur en série
retour sur l'affaire qui a traumatisé la
Belgique ces dernières semaines
comment les policiers seraient parvenus
à identifier une autre victime
[Musique]
et il a été arrêté ici
ont commencé l'enquête ils ont pris son
ADN
et grâce à cela ils ont remonté d'autres
pistes ils sont tombés sur une affaire
de meurtre non élucidé
une femme de 82 ans
Mario Vacher
qui est étonnant c'est qu'en plus de
l'ADN
elle aurait été têtu de la même manière
il paraît qu'elle avait des blessures
importantes des blessures très graves à
la tête elle a été mortellement blessée
avec un bâton
exactement comme Linda d'homme
en mai 2014 un livreur de journaux
signal que Maria valshire ne récupère
plus son journal dans sa boîte aux
lettres cette veuve de 82 ans est
découverte par son fils morte depuis au
moins trois jours des suites d'une
violente agression avec un bâton
mais par contre quand par exemple c'est
triste on a du mal à accepter
ses voisins ont d'abord pensé qu'elle
était partie en vacances avant
d'apprendre la terrible nouvelle
[Musique]
je me réveille parfois et je pense à
Maria je me dis c'est pas possible
elle était renfermée isolée elle était
très indépendante
mais elle n'avait pas peur parce que la
semaine avant j'étais avec elle et on
parlait des cambriolages elle disait
qu'elle n'avait pas peur
Renaud Hardy aurait-il pu tuer cette
vieille dame qui ne semblait pas
connaître
les coups portaient avec un bâton ce
mode opératoire rappelle étrangement le
meurtre de Linda Doms des traces d'ADN
aurait été retrouvées sur la scène de
crime mais à l'époque cette ADN masculin
n'avait pas pu être identifié ce n'est
qu'après l'arrestation de Renault Hardy
pour l'assassinat de Linda Doms que les
enquêteurs découvrent qu'il s'agiraient
bien du même ADN l'homme pourrait être
impliqué dans le meurtre de Maria
valcherts pourquoi les aurait-il tué qui
est réellement cet homme au profil très
inquiétant
Renoir dit à 53 ans il a grandi à maline
avec ses parents essaient de sœurs
sa mère vit toujours dans le quartier
nous sommes allés la rencontrer elle est
effondrée depuis l'arrestation de son
fils bonjour je suis journaliste je
viens de parler
[Musique]
encore aujourd'hui
je ne peux pas le voir tellement que
j'étais
enchanté c'est pas le petit gamin que
vous avez élevé
il était il était comment quand il était
petit
à travailler comme agent d'entretien
dans cette salle de sport
mais en 2016 il découvre qu'il est
atteint de la maladie de Parkinson
désormais en arrêt maladie il consacre
tout son temps à sa nouvelle passion la
photo
mais il s'y a donne d'une manière
particulière
il ne cherche que des femmes comme
modèle
c'est comme cela qu'il approche Sophie
âgé de 50 ans dans un bar de son
quartier il lui propose une séance photo
gratuite chez lui elle accepte mais son
mari n'est pas rassuré
mon mari m'a dit tu ne le connais pas
imagine s'il t'arrive quelque chose
alors on s'est fixé une heure
à ce moment là avec vous est-ce qu'il
était gentil est-ce qu'il a essayé de
vous charmer
non rien du tout j'ai tout de suite dit
pas de drague je suis mariée donc on
fait cette séance photo sans rien
attendre d'autre
on en reste là
suite à cette séance photo le mari de
Sophie reçoit des messages étranges de
Renaud Hardy
avec un exemplaire comme ça au lit
vous devez être heureux au lit avec
un exemplaire comme ça
le photographe ne s'arrête pas là il lui
envoie aussi des blagues salaces sur les
femmes
comment on appelle la viande autour
d'une vasine c'est ça du vagin
non je suis pas si bien en biologie
alors lui il faut ah ça c'est une femme
ça montre déjà que de respect pour une
femme c'est pas
dans son quartier Renaud Hardy n'avait
pas bonne réputation
[Musique]
ce commerçant est encore choqué de son
comportement
c'est quelqu'un qui parlait des
prostituées de la cocaïne comme c'était
rien un certain jour il était là il
était en train de parler des femmes aux
clients on peut parler de femmes il y a
des limites
son comportement malsain vers les femmes
est aussi constaté chez une de ses
voisines elle l'avait surprise à
plusieurs reprises en train de
l'espionner et sa méthode est incroyable
[Musique]
j'aime bien mais avec un short ou avec
un truc comme ça et alors j'attends
quelque chose qui fait du bruit alors je
regarde
c'est quoi ça certains moments j'ai
couru j'ai peur et je crois qu'elle a vu
ça parce que moi je croyais que c'est
que ça va tomber sur moi ou quelque
chose
je savais pas en fait qu'est-ce que
c'est
l'objet que cette voisine a surpris est
en fait un drone
un objet volant télécommandé
en plus de la photo Renaud a dit film
avec son appareil les maisons de son
quartier et surtout des voisines
voici une de ces vidéos personnelles que
nous nous sommes procurées on le voit
déambuler au-dessus des jardins des
voisins
cette méthode d'espionnage aurait
peut-être poussé Renault Hardy à s'en
prendre à une de ses voisines en début
d'année
c'est en tout cas la conviction des
enquêteurs d'autant plus que son ADN
aurait été retrouvé sur le lieu de
l'agression
et ce n'est pas une voisine banale que
l'homme est soupçonné d'avoir traqué
il s'agit d'une actrice de Téléfilm
connue en Belgique vers les Eckermann
nous l'avons contacté mais elle ne
souhaite pas être interviewée traumatisé
elle nous confie qu'à la crue mourir ce
jour-là
[Musique]
le 14 février dernier vers 22 heures
l'actrice rentre chez elle
c'est à ce moment-là qu'un homme qu'elle
n'a pas pu identifier lui saute dessus
et la tabasse là aussi avec un bâton
elle ne doit son salut qu'elle arrive et
d'un voisin qui fait fuir la graisseur
elle s'en sortira avec 18 points de
suture à la tête et un important
traumatisme crânien
vers les Eckermann Linda Doms Maria
Vacher n'avait aucun lien entre elle
aurait-elle pu être victime de la même
pulsion meurtrière
c'est la réponse que tente d'apporter
les enquêteurs en réouvrant toutes les
affaires non élucidées dans la région
un travail titanesque
mais s'il reconnaît pour l'instant le
meurtre de Linda dôme Renaud ardini
l'intégralité des autres faits
incarcéré à la maison d'arrêt de Forest
il devra être jugé dans les prochains
mois pour le meurtre de Linda Doms et
Maria valshore
si les condamné pour ses meurtres il
risque la perpétuité
[Musique]